hey guys what's up this is andrew from
trendsenses.com so in this video guys i
want to go through amc press action i
want to have a look at everything that
happened this week we had a good week we
have a bullish signal that happened two
weeks ago so let's analyze if it's still
valid and what can happen next let's get
into it
[Music]
all right guys as usual daily timeframe
so i have a couple of things uh to tell
you in this video first we have earnings
coming uh first of march trading view by
the way saying third of march it has
been updated to first of march yes so
this is the day of earnings
uh on the daily timeframe we have this
breakout guys that we have analyzed
quickly uh last week we're gonna go
through that again and what i first want
to do guys is quickly analyze with you
this earnings situation so here as you
can see i put some
blue bars all right each time the
earnings were coming okay
and i just want to see in the past here
how did the market react to earnings
prior to earnings and after earnings all
right so
the most recent earnings were uh in
november they were good and as you can
see the market started to be
bullish
two weeks before that so it was about
the rumor and when the earnings arrived
as you can see guys 8th of november we
were here this trend line was already
existing because we already had this
high and this high so this trend line
was real
and we arrived on the resistance
and we got sold despite the good
earnings that were surprisingly positive
by 17 percent guys
so we were in the by the rumors of the
news situation i think we are again in
this situation i'm gonna discuss that
very soon
but let's check before what happened
again then here 9th of august earnings
were good
surprise of 24
up
and
this time it was rather the market was
bearish
clearly
and the good earnings helped us to be
bullish the next month so what we can
say here is that on the day of the
earnings we arrive this time not only
resistance but on a support and each
time as you can see earnings
are
making the trend shift okay we're back
from bearish to bullish and from bullish
to bearish so you know it looks like it
is a catalyzer but it doesn't look for
now i have only analyzed two of them
that earnings are actually giving the
direction depending on how good they are
or not you know they're just market
shifters
but you know good earnings
we have already seen can
uh make the market go from bearish to
bullish or from bullish to bearish so
okay
first thing then we have two more those
were bad
and look guys bad earnings so sell the
rumor
buy the news okay so again on the day of
the earnings we are out of support and
again the market shifted guys okay as
you can see we were bearish for the
past
two months and we had the
the squeeze guys all right this are good
memories
i mean good or bad you can see it
whatever you want for me they're good
memories and this created the screen so
again the past three earnings were
market shifters i mean trend shifters
not sure i can say that but the trend
has shifted
uh just on the day of the earnings i
mean the day of the earnings is at the
low always at a support level as you can
see guys here the trend line can be done
as well before that day
i mean we exceeded a little bit okay
let's be honest we're just below the
stream land but to me we are on a
support i'm using the regular scale
usually i'm using the log scale guys
but i've seen that the regular scale is
more adapted for the short term for what
is happening right now on the short term
so i can switch from regular to large
depending on what i think fits the best
and the reason why i do that is
regarding this breakout i'm going to
come to this breakout very soon guys i
just want to finish on the uh earnings
and then the fourth earnings
the on the only time it was in the
middle of the trend and it was not a
market mover i mean they were super
negative and it didn't change much but
the past three earnings quarterly
earnings were trend shifters right
so we can expect that
the same thing happens again so let's
analyze a little bit more the situation
that we're having here before earnings
because earnings guys are gonna come i
put the blue line here first of march
all right guys it was announced by adam
aaron uh yesterday or a few days ago i'm
not sure
yesterday we are the 19th of feb today
so it was announced yesterday i think
and so the first of march we're going to
have this earnings and so what is this
situation first b4 earnings because it's
important too okay because we can expect
that the trend shifts so what is the
trend first
uh so to know the trend you look at the
past okay in the past we were in the
bearish trend and here
so guys
it's it's not easy to say what's going
to happen let's be honest but let me
give you what i think might happen
we weren't a better trend right and here
so
i'm trying to analyze this move for the
past two months guys and as you know i
told you after this breakout that
things are looking really bad and that
we need time as i'm still saying we need
time by the way some say that the
squeeze is going to come
this week or next week i don't believe
that right i think
we will see again some crazy news on amc
but we need time i told you already my
target is maybe around april may let's
see i might change that depending on
what happens you know until april or may
of course
so i will just keep telling you what uh
i believe is the more likely scenario
and for now we have this uh this trend
that is going down
and we have this breakup guys okay so a
breakout is
you know an event that is making the
trend shift it's a reversal signal that
enhances a new trend is arriving if the
breakout is good quality and here we
have already seen that this breakout
happen on increasing volume
true
here increasing volume okay that's good
did we have a consolidation before
breakout we did but we saw that this
consideration so first happened on so it
was not perfect why it was not perfect
because as you can see the consideration
is not very close to the trend line
first thing second thing it didn't
happen on low volume we have here a
massive red day during this
consolidation so this is not a good
quality consolidation we are above the
20 day moving average which is necessary
for a good and reliable breakout and
what else bollinger bands and they were
not super tight guys all right they were
okay they are getting tighter now but
during the breakout they were not super
tight
so as i'm gonna explain to you guys for
those who are interested in the course
that by the way is ready guys he's
complete i'm finished with all the
videos i'm finished with everything i
just need to make some little details uh
better on my website but everything
regarding the course is ready and for
those who are interested just click on
the link
at the bottom of this video so you're
going to be in the list and receive a 50
discount so uh in this course basically
what you will get is not only some
material that is going to help you guys
to trade breakouts and to understand how
to use volume volatility momentum all
these indicators to actually assess what
is the market sentiment you also gonna
get access guys to a forum which is a
place where uh we're gonna share trade
ideas a little bit like we're doing this
code but we're gonna apply the course
and we're gonna see we're gonna try to
find the best training setups and
they're gonna be some
experienced traders guys that are gonna
help you to see if the setups you are
proposing are good to train or not and
i'm actually right now recruiting a team
yeah it's gonna be a team of killers uh
you just need to give me a little bit of
time i wanna bring some really good guys
in this place but for now they're not
here it's gonna take me a little bit of
time but you know i'm trying to make
something big guys something huge you
know and that is gonna help you to
really understand how to make those uh
trades that are based on the signals i'm
showing you guys here on breakouts and
volatility momentum like i said volume
of course
and and yeah this is what i'm trying to
do guys so if you're interested just
click on this thing guys so you're going
to be in the list and it's going to come
in one or two weeks all right let's go
back to amc
uh so here like i said this breakout is
good quality but not perfect for the
reasons i've just given you guys so what
can we expect we still have earnings
coming we have a breakout so to me i
don't see any reason we don't enter to
buy the rumor i think the earnings are
going to be better than expected i don't
know what you think but this is to me
the really
you know usual situation for the by the
rumor situation okay because we think
earnings are going to be better because
it's fourth quarter earnings 21. there
was spider-man guys in the cinema i mean
you know there are a lot of good things
that are showing that earnings might be
better than expected so my take as we
have the breakout we have the earnings
we have the 20-day moving average coming
here maybe we're going to retest this
level so which is around 17 right now i
told you that 18 is the support so okay
we're under 18 21 range so i still
believe that we need to consider it a
little bit more in that range but the
20-day moving average is coming just
here so my thing is that maybe we go
test it a little bit
and then
you know
maybe maybe guys maybe go there
to be honest it seems a bit far
but
you know maybe a strong move happening
just before earnings and then
unfortunately getting sold okay
so i think that we might be in such in
this situation okay something like this
right
it's not exactly the same situation but
because here it's a long-term downtrend
that we just broke out from
so i don't know i think that we might
rally guys just before earnings and then
yeah once again pause a little bit take
a little bit of time and then you know
around once again everyone may have the
big move coming
oh right guys so
you want to check the synthetic short
app okay guys so i'm checking as you
know
the synthetic shot because i know that
you are interested in this information
and of course i'm following that closely
guys
all the time
connected all right it's going to
refresh by itself
okay 18th of feb is done so 18 plus 725
okay i'm gonna add one maturity
this one i need it
and then much okay so okay then i
updated the strikes
okay it's coming
here we go
let me retrieve the synthetic line
so here i'm retrieving the put options
okay so i have put options ready cool
options ready this is the 25th of feb
now
all right
so the max pen is around 20 for the
fifth 25th of feb okay we could it's not
very important it's not a big expiry you
guys need to be honest so what do we
have what is the regular short so 18 of
dance do i have the value for the 28th
of jan right because
remember we were supposed to have some
shorts covering
it's still not it
okay but it's not available guys
so we're going to discuss that later
um so i'm going back to the 14th of jan
and okay so
nothing big guys all right there's no
new information from here the synthetic
shot is currently positive yes so we
have some synthetic shot it's 1.2
percent the regular shot is 18 the dtc
is two i'm gonna add it here and as you
can see we don't have big moves guys
since last week okay pretty much the
same gtc was two now it's 1.96
the maximum synthetic shot is a little
bit lower because we had the fab fab
expiry where we had a lot of options but
it's going to rebuild so we are back to
12.6 which is not big guys all right
let's be honest it's one of the lowest
level we had
since like august 21. so what can i say
here once again this confirms to me that
we need time guys the option market is
not uh incredible right now compared to
what it was before
so i think that retail investors are
waiting a little bit no one you know
some are scared that we go lower
you know we're still in the shock uh
after what happened the past two three
months guys because we lost seventy
percent all right even more than uh
where we where we
of value compared to where we were at
the top so investors need time
and when i'm going to see this
rebuilding strongly a lot of collapses
coming guys this is gonna be once again
the signal that things are getting hot
again and i'm not the only one looking
at that guys you know uh market makers
asset managers hedge funds looking at
this data as well and they're feeling
the same as i do that for now there's
nothing
you know very hot let's be honest so
we're still bullish guys we have
earnings coming i think we're gonna be
in the buy the rumor sell the new
situation so let's see if i am correct
about that once again it's only my
opinion guys i might be wrong but i'm
just giving you my scenario i can give
you the alternative scenario guys of
course is that 17 doesn't hold we go
lower we go back to the 14 level and
bam then here if we come back to 14 just
before earnings the earnings might be
once again a trend shifter so how do we
go higher and then lower or lower and
higher guys right so you know this is
what we've seen we've seen that in the
past earnings
good or bad they are just making the
trend shift so we can expect the same to
happen this time so that's it for me i
hope you guys enjoyed this video and if
you did please don't forget to click on
the sub like and bell button so you're
going to be the first to know when i
upload anything new and stay close to
shore i'll see you guys